i I don't I don't I don't understand why  you continue to ask me last year--last  market this finish why why for which  reason why we continue to ask me last  year you had the other chance to go I  stay here because my work is here I work  for together I built with the chairman  with the owner this team we want three  trophies in two years for 15 years you  didn't we never never take to a  respectful for the people sometime okay  I don't understand why we continue to  ask me this why Leslie Friday's comments  aside and i'll respect you ask me one  question I'm I'm no no I'm polite  because I answered your question and the  other question I also did the answer  because I I may have to talk about with  them